dieser mann verändert gerade die welt
voll seit sein ziel weniger
kindesmissbrauch und er hat gerade eine
weltumspannende bewegung gegründet the
brave movement frei übersetzt die
bewegung der tapferen denn menschen die
missbraucht worden sind keine opfer
sondern überlebende des missbrauchs und
mit dem brett movement haben sie schon
nach einem monat stellen so jung ist die
bewegung ein riesenziel erreicht thanks
for giving erzähle ich ihnen noch
unregelmäßigen abständen die geschichten
von menschen die sich für eine gute
sache einsetzen abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
falls hat erfahrung damit
unerreichbare ziele zu erreichen denn
schon bei seinem engagement gegen aids
hat er ziele erreicht die andere für
unmöglich hielten ihre produkte mögen
dass wir haben eine parteiübergreifende
politische bewegung ins leben gerufen
die glaubens führer studierende und alle
möglichen fachleute zusammen brachte um
ein politisches umfeld zu schaffen das
präsident bush dazu veranlasste einen
notfallplan zur aids-bekämpfung
aufzustellen alle sagten dass das nicht
möglich sein dass präsident bush das nie
tun würde das die führenden politiker
der welt das nie tun würden und sie
taten
doch dann merkte seitz dass irgendetwas
nicht mit ihm stimmte
in meinen späten 40ern vor etwa 13
jahren hatte ich ein erlebnis bei dem
ich mich daran erinnerte dass ich ein
überlebender war dass sich mit einer
amnesie barriere gelebt hatte das heißt
mit einer neuen erinnerung ich wusste
dass ich verkorkst war ich war
aufgewühlt und ich wusste nicht warum
ich arbeitete an mir warum bin ich so
wütend warum hasse ich mich so sehr
warum quäle ich mich so und ich habe
daran gearbeitet mich selbst zu heilen
und in den jahren 2008 und 2009 hatte
ich eine art von erinnerungs rückkehr
ich erinnerte mich dass mein vater der
täter war und dann ergab alles in meinem
leben irgendwie ein sinn als würde es
bei mir klick machen deshalb ist das
passiert deshalb ist das passiert
deshalb habe ich auf diese oder jene
weise reagiert und weil ich mich für
aids eingesetzt hatte und teil einer
wirklich erfolgreichen globalen bewegung
war verpflichtete ich mich damals alles
in meiner macht stehende zu tun um für
andere kinder die jetzt leben und für
alle zukünftigen generationen alles zu
tun was ich kann um der sexuellen gewalt
in der kindheit ein ende zu setzen denn
ich war der meinung dass kein kind das
durch machen sollte was ich durchgemacht
habe es ist die hölle es ist folter es
ist erschütternd es ist verheerend es
ruiniert das eigene leben
jetzt der bruins und mit seiner
erfahrung seiner energie konnte er jetzt
eine ganze bewegung gründen das brave
movement und das hat es in sich alpen
würde ich konnte mit vielen führenden
überlebenden zusammen arbeiten und auch
mit der foundation die sehr großzügig zu
uns war und uns einen sehr hohen
zuschuss von zehn millionen dollar
ausschließlich für die
interessenvertretung und kampagnenarbeit
gewährt hat das ist der grund dafür dass
das brave buben so schnell vorankommen
kann wie wir es tun es gibt buchstäblich
hunderte von millionen vielleicht sogar
milliarden von menschen die direkte
erfahrung mit sexueller gewalt in der
kindheit gemacht haben oder aus familien
stammen in denen sexuelle gewalt
stattgefunden hat wir versuchen also
diese stimmen wachzurütteln und zu
erheben und unsere kräfte zu bündeln um
wirklich und so schnell wie möglich
etwas zu erreichen und wir machen große
fortschritte und der nächste schritt ist
gigantisch die bewegung will zehn
milliarden dollar für den kampf gegen
den kindesmissbrauch denn um dieses ziel
zu erreichen hat die auch von dacian die
zehn millionen dollar bereitgestellt die
g7 staaten sollen bei ihrem gipfel im
juni auf schloss elmau diese mittel
beschließen diese forderung stellte die
bewegung auf einer pressekonferenz in
berlin auf zurzeit hat deutschland die
präsidentschaft der g 7 staaten und die
bundesregierung hat ihre unterstützung
bereits zugesagt
tatsächlich scheint jetzt ein sehr sehr
guter moment zu sein um dieses ziel auch
zu erreichen
bei klinkenbuchse woraufhin ich glaube
die globale kultur entwickelt sich
weiter ich denke dass die miete bewegung
jetzt entstanden ist und diese
entwickelt und verändert sich immer noch
und wir sind teil der kids zu bewegen
wir sagen das nicht nur erwachsene
frauen von sexueller gewalt betroffen
sind sondern auch kinder also kids zu
und dass auch erwachsene männer in
bestimmten umgebung sexuelle gewalt
erleben ich denke wir sind wie eine
welle eine revolution der kinderrechte
der frauenrechte und der menschenrechte
die miete bewegung ist ein katalysator
wir sind mit dieser bewegung solidarisch
und schließlich treten erwachsene
überlebende sexueller gewalt in der
kindheit vor und erheben die forderung
und den ruf nach mutigem handeln und man
hört uns zu und wir werden gehört und
das ist wirklich inspirierend und
ihr du ihr könnt auch etwas gutes tun
denn die industrienationen wie
deutschland sind bei diesem fonds
ausgeschlossen ich selbst unterstütze ja
die initiative umsteuern hier geht es
darum leute zu motivieren die aus der
kirche ausgetreten sind den gesparten
betrag bei umsteuern zu spenden damit
will die initiative etwas für die
menschen tun die von der kirche
missbraucht und diskriminiert worden das
erste projekt ist die beratungsstelle
leuchtzeichen die unabhängig von der
kirche berät klickt hier für mehr infos
und updates zum thema die links sind
auch in der video beschreibung und im
ersten kommentar es würde mir wirklich
sehr viel bedeuten wenn wir hier bald
das erste ziel erreichen würden was es
ist das könnte hier sind liegt also
drauf dann erfahrt ihr mehr biss dann
bleibt dran